joining me now is the shadow ex-checker
secretary to the treasury abina
zari hello to you thanks for joining us
on the program this morning it's great
to see you good morning uh right we're
still waiting to um hear what's
happening as far as sue gray is
concerned we'll come back to that in
just a second windfall tax biggest uh
clue yet from the government this
morning that potentially it's on the
cards
i saw that this morning um i saw simon
clark do his interview with you saying
that the government was um looking into
this
the reality of the situation is that
labour has been calling for this as you
know for quite some months there is a
real urgency in terms of the fact that
the windfall tax needs to be implemented
we're in the middle of a cost of living
crisis
where households are facing the biggest
squeeze
in 30 years in my constituency i'm
having constituents that aren't able to
get the bus to go and get support in
terms of from the food bank or being
able to go to the job centre it's we
need urgency from the government and i'm
just disappointed to hear from simon
clark to say
that they're waiting to see from the gas
companies in terms of um showing
leadership on this you know the
government's empowered now they've been
powerful 12 years i don't understand why
what the diver and delay is you know gas
and all producers have made huge profits
during this time and it's increasing
it's just a no-brainer in terms of the
fact that the government should get on
with it how should it be used okay so
what labour's been proposing is that
with the windfall tax that we're
proposing this money would be used to
help people in terms it will take up to
600 pounds of their energy bills should
it be across the board
so this is tested i have to say though
um you know it doesn't matter whether
you're i know that people that are
middle incomes whether they're not
taking benefits they are also massively
impacted you know things are really
difficult not as much as people who
can't afford to put their meter on and
are using candles to light their rooms
and um
so my question again is should it be
means tested or not i i don't believe it
should be mean tested because everybody
should get it i i'll say that everyone
is is feeling the pinch um i think the
chancellor is i'm not here to talk about
whether the chancellor is i'm talking
about the majority of individuals i've
seen it from speaking to people on the
doorstep we recently had elections
things are really difficult for
individuals but people in multi-million
pound homes should not be getting 600
quid when actually it could more money
could be given to those who need it most
surely i'd say what the government has
done at the moment which is um introduce
um
increase in insurance contribution and
sorry
national insurance contributions um is
not the best time to be doing that
because it's just making people's
situations worse
which is why we feel that a windfall tax
you know would make things a lot better
because it should be targeted to people
who need it most well it will take up to
600 pounds of bills for people that
really need it to be honest
people in the middle there are fees that
feel in the pinch right now
and people and multimedia as you
probably see
with
one of the energy companies yesterday
was talking about how the fact that you
know
come october september bills are going
to increase dramatically you may think
right now that this isn't impacting a
certain amount of people but by
september october if the government
doesn't get a grip on this it will just
make things a lot worse for individuals
talk to me about the sue gray report um
it's uh it's coming up the prime
minister's uh had one fine he's not
getting any more fines he's not going
anywhere
well i think in terms of the sue grey
report i do feel that it's important
that the investigation takes place i
really want to see what the outcome of
this comes out of this i'd say that i'm
going to be putting my constituents at
the forefront of this they've made
really difficult decisions in some cases
some people weren't able to say goodbye
to their loved ones whereas the prime
minister um has you know we've heard
that they've been having parties
one thing that i do want to see from the
prime minister is to show some
leadership on this i don't want my
concern is that you know we're going to
see um some junior staffers having to
take the blame for this you know the
prime minister needs to show some
leadership and really demonstrate that
you know he's learned from his actions
and something needs to be done how would
that manifest itself what do you want to
see
well we need to see what comes up the
sugar report first i don't want to
pre-judge it we don't have to we've seen
the highlights but we haven't seen the
the report in detail no he's going to be
criticized well i know before i before i
make that judgment i want to see what
comes out of the report and i want to
see what i want i want to see he has
been criticized but i want to see what
comes out the recommendations from sue
gray you know i think uh sigre is you
know is a civil servant who is you know
is acted really responsibly and you know
i trust her judgment and i really want
to see what comes out of that first
before we make some kind of judgment on
what should be done following the sue
grey report it's only been fined once so
and it could be that your boss is in the
same position
i'd say that the situation with um with
kirsten is is different where um the
tier system was completely different and
it was a meal at the end of the day but
you know one thing that um kirsten has
done
is that he said you know if he is fined
he will step down from that and i
believe that is much more strong
leadership than what the prime minister
has demonstrated throughout this
whole situation
okay and talk to me though about the
meeting that allegedly took place
between sue gray and the prime minister
actually it's confirmed that the meeting
took place does it actually matter who
called that meeting i mean all we know
at this stage is that a meeting has
taken place
sue grace says that she didn't call this
meeting we haven't really heard from the
prime minister whether he called the
meeting or not and that to me
is quite concerning to be honest and in
terms of the fact that there is a lack
of transparency if it's not a big deal
why doesn't the prime minister say well
who called the meeting
but at this stage you know we do need
answers on that but we also need to see
what comes out from the sue grey report
does it concern labor that there was a
meeting at all actually given that we we
all agree that sue gray has a massive
integrity
why does it matter whether a meeting
took place or not well to be honest i'm
not saying that it matters whether
meeting took place or not i don't know
what happened within that meeting so
it's very difficult for me to comment
but what i do find quite baffling is
that we can't get any answers as to who
called the meeting
which you know does come across to me as
quite concerning to be honest on that we
don't know what's been discussed in that
meeting
until we find that those details it's
very difficult to make a judgment as to
you know why this meeting took place or
whether it was appropriate
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us on the programme this morning just
bear with us a second if you were
pleased thank you